hey guys in this week's video we're
going to talk about skin care
specifically about redness on your face
so what causes redness on your face and
how do you get rid of it
well that's what i'm going to show you
let's jump into it
[Music]
alright guys so what causes redness on
your face
do you know
well there are basically five things
five causes and you need to know them
because if you don't know the problem
how will you be able to find a solution
you can't
so let's start with number one sensitive
skin
two lifestyle choices like rough
environments and prolonged sun damage
alcohol
spicy food
and stress
three you can get redness from acne four
you can get it from rosacea now let's
just pause here for a second rosacea is
a lot more common than you might think
because it is estimated that 1 out of 10
people have rosacea
so if the world has a population of 8
billion in 2020 10 of that is 800
million and that's how many people might
have rosacea five you can get redness
from eczema and allergic reactions
now if you have eczema or allergic
reactions it's better just to go see a
doctor because he or she will help you a
lot better than i can
but with all the other causes i can
definitely help you so how do you get
rid of redness on your face well first
you need to stop all the bad habits that
are causing redness on your skin if
you're drinking stop drinking so much
and stop going into the sun without sun
protection
and stop going into rough environments
without protecting your skin look our
skin is amazing and it can take a lot
but if you keep on forcing it to take
damage day after day after day of the
day what's gonna happen it is just going
to get worse
so start to protect it by using a good
skin care routine
i use geology they develop a unique
skincare routine for my specific skin
care concerns
so that means i can go into the sun or
go fishing or do whatever even in tough
environments without worrying too much
about my skin they also decided to
sponsor today's video and give you guys
70
off through my dlm discount code i'll
add it for you in the video description
down below geology is simple yet
powerful skin care for men with no
fillers no fads and no marketing
nonsense it is built around trusted and
proven ingredients that are used by
dermatologists
guys it is especially important to use
trusted and scientifically proven
products don't just use anything for
your skin
every person's skin's condition and what
it needs is different
it's not the same so why do you want to
use the same products that everybody
else are using
this is what makes geology different
because they first determine your skin's
concerns when you answer a few questions
on their website and then they formulate
a unique skincare routine for you
the basic skincare routine will help you
with your redness and also lessen
inflammation
now if your skin is red because of
pimples acne or inflamed pimples you
will need to use skin care products
that will kill the bacteria in your skin
as well as have
anti-inflammatory properties this is
very important guys you need to choose
the right products for your skin and
look for products that are
scientifically proven to work
like azelaic acid and retinol which
fight breakouts helps healthy cells grow
and improves your skin tone oh yeah
before i forget if it's the first time
that you're here my name is daniel and
welcome to my channel if you like the
video so far chances are you'll probably
like the other videos on my channel as
well so subscribe and if you don't want
to subscribe just do it anyway i would
really like the support now another good
ingredient that you can trust is
salicylic acid it reduces inflammation
kills the bacteria and removes excess
oil now if you choose to try geology
they will put some of these ingredients
into your skincare routine so you don't
even have to worry about it now if you
have sensitive skin it is even more
important for you to use the right
ingredients use the right products if
you use the wrong things with fragrances
in it with alcohol in it it can and
probably will aggravate your skin and it
will just get worse
now rosacea and occasional flushing of
the skin that's
difficult to deal with i'm not gonna lie
to you here so the key here is to
identify the triggers and then handle it
appropriately make appropriate lifestyle
changes like staying away from the sun
drinking too much environmental factors
and so on the other thing that will help
you is to use the right skin care
products that contain clinically proven
ingredients
you can look out for caffeine allentown
and niacinamide caffeine because it has
an antioxidant effect reduces under eye
redness energizes skin cells and
decreases puffiness
next up is allentoine it is great at
healing injured skin it calms skin down
from being irritant or inflammatory
increases the skin's moisture absorption
and it also helps with cellular
regeneration then niacinamide improves
skin tone and defense it helps you to
regulate oil production
and it also has anti-inflammatory
properties now my best advice is just to
try geology you get 70 off anyway and if
you don't like it well you can always
just cancel it but chances are that you
will like it just like i do
if you have any other questions on
grooming skin care well basically
anything has got to do with men check
out these playlists here and you might
like it and before you go always
remember
life is short so don't waste yours
cheers guys